[Music]
hello
i'm alexander rose the executive
director here at long now
today we have a slightly different
format for our usual talks we're
actually
doing this as a conversation i'm going
to be welcoming nathaniel rich
at the occasion of his newest book
called second nature
and i'm also going to be welcoming to
interview him uh ryan phelan the
executive director at revive and restore
and the lead scientist at revive and
restore
ben novak we're joining from three
different locations and putting this
conversation together
the goal here is to is to not only talk
about
second nature nathaniel rich's new book
but really as a kind of
an update on science that's been going
on for quite some time
in bringing back extinct species or
designing new species
to be better adapted for our current
world
and revive and restore was a project
that was originally incubated here at
long now was held founded by
uh stuart brand one of our founders it's
now spun off into its own non-profit
but nathaniel rich has been studying
this as a journalist now for almost
10 years or more and he has brought
together i think both the science that
that has been worked on at revive and
restore as well as some new science from
around the world
and it's all together in this book and
in this conversation for you today
welcome nathaniel rich thank you xander
it's a pleasure to be here at the
interval um
after reading nathaniel rich's
intriguing book
called second nature which is just out
nathaniel rich you're calling in here
from
new orleans louisiana great well welcome
and we also have ben novak um my
colleague here at revive and restore our
lead scientist
ben hi ryan uh greetings from north
carolina and
nathaniel it's great to be talking again
well nathaniel
welcome to along now talk i'm here
in san francisco at the interval and
it's really a pleasure
to get to interview you in a sense
ben novak and i get to turn the tables
on you
having been interviewed by you back in
2014
for your article in the new york times
magazine
the mammoth cometh it was a major cover
story for us
and and i must say uh quite
controversial at the time because you
really probed deep on something that was
still
very early on in its gestation the
bringing back of a passenger pigeon
we were delighted when we heard that you
were actually
going to include that article or an
update on that article
in your new book called second nature
it's really a thrill to
to be back with both of you even if
virtually
the story that i you know reported so
many years ago
about revive and restore um was so
foundational in my thinking for second
nature it was really
in our conversations my conversations
with both of you as well as
with stuart brand where i i was first
really given the language
um to articulate uh some
some themes that had really been um you
know puzzling me obsessing me
fascinating me for some time
and it was it was really through the
process of writing that story that i
began to see a kind of larger
um you know landscape uh unfold before
me and i found myself returning to this
these same themes over and over again um
in the years since and
and the results of that work really the
work of of the last decade
um is is second nature well since that
time you've interviewed an
amazing cast of characters for this book
and i must say when i first started the
book it seemed like
quite a disparate group of uh
interviews from talking to people who
were involved in the oil and gas
industry
from southern california to louisiana
to uh artists working uh
you know with um fluorescent green
rabbits
um it's it's of the full gamut and it's
been really interesting
as one reads through it connecting those
dots
in how we intervene in nature um i'd
love for you to
talk us through a little bit about how
you structured that
that theme throughout of second nature
yeah so the the basic idea of the book
and
and the you know basic problem i was
trying to
investigate is that you know there's
nothing
uh natural about the natural world
anymore that anything that we
describe uh as nature or wilderness
um doesn't hold up under scrutiny to
um our our definitions of those words
and and
you know the the the basic ideas we've
reconfigured um
every part of the planet from the you
know every cubic inch of soil to
to the atmosphere through our activities
sometimes
uh through neglect sometimes through
malice
sometimes in through some kind of
misplaced virtue
and the first the first section of the
book is this realization that this has
happened which i think is a very
you know disillusioning and unsettling
idea that that
took a long time for me to really come
to terms with personally so the first
stories in the book
are about people who um are in this have
a moment of personal crisis
once they they realize that the world as
they they thought it to be
uh doesn't is no longer there or that
that their basic ideas about the natural
world
um were kind of myth uh the second
section of stories is about
people who are navigating the basically
the weirdness or the the uncanny
quality of our reality today when we're
living it in this time where
um there's so much unnatural about about
our natural world and and the final
section
um is about people who like yourselves
who are trying
um as best as they can to use
some of these incredibly powerful
technologies
um that we've we've with which we've you
know re-sculpted the the planet
um and trying to use those same powers
to restore um
what we've lost um or to make the the
world feel at least more natural even if
the idea of of
you know natural is something of a of a
simulacrum
well i think for the long now audience
it's important to think about
how this book relates to long-term
thinking and
it's a really great example of looking
both
at the history of many of these species
and
of what we saw as wilderness in the past
to actually
um thinking through the social cultural
and civilization
aspect of it especially when we get to
louisiana and
all the devastation there and havoc that
has been wrought
i'm curious uh if you want to add some
flavor to that
long arc of covering both wilderness
and covering civilization yeah i mean i
think
one of the first insights one has when
you start to look into this is that it's
very hard to separate or impossible to
separate you know
human uh beings in our society from
natural world at least as long as we've
been on the planet and we've been
civilized and i started the book with
one of my favorite examples
i was once driving up the coast northern
california
um by the town of fort bragg and it's
it's famous
for this this beautiful glass beach
which is in a
little cove off the highway
and it's you know filled with pieces of
sea glass
um and i i stopped there like a
thousand other tourists that stopped
there every day and and walked down to
the beach and
and i was told by some people there that
oh you know this this beach used to be
more
um more beautiful there used to be a lot
more sea glass but all of these
tourists are taking this to the sea
glass and so it's sort of ruining the
this natural beauty of the
of the beach and they would use that
term natural beauty and i said
but that was really interesting and i i
i learned furthermore that there was an
effort to
bring more sea glass to the beach uh
to to you know revive its its its
natural glory and
it was only after reading about it and
thinking about it a little more that i
realized what they were talking about
which is that
the glass beach was the city dump and it
was
you know the glass it's just it's just
that it's just broken glass and you know
tupperware and things like that from the
1940s and 50s
um that had been buffed and you know
polished by the
by the surf um over the years and
and what uh and what people are when
people are talking about replenishing
the glass they were talking about
dumping more trash essentially onto the
beach
um and and that to me is kind of the
oh and then the final twist is that the
leader of this effort
um this local sea captain retired sea
captain who runs the sea glass museum in
fort bragg
um he was appealing on an ecological
basis to the state saying that if your
mission is really as it says in the you
know the charter
to restore or protect natural beauty
then you should be protecting
the glass beach because it fits your
criteria in all these ways and
i thought you know he's on one level
he's so
wrong and on the other level sort of
right you know
and that that's where i feel like that
nexus this kind of eerie tension between
you know what's natural what's unnatural
you know when we talk about beautiful
things how much are we admiring
ourselves versus admiring
nature um and how are these things
enmeshed and
and how do you detangle them um i feel
like we're
this is very much the story of our of
our time
um and in terms of of long now i mean i
also
you know speaking with you all about
you know long deep time and and and you
know
enlarging one's framework on on time and
human history
also helped clarify to me that
i feel you know every generation thinks
it's the most important generation in
the history of the planet but i do feel
that right now we're on
this fascinating precipice where um
you know we've already altered the world
in so many ways
but we're only now starting to take
responsibility for having done so and
only now beginning to think about
well if we're going to be altering you
know if
if it's inevitable that we're altering
the world you know how can we do so
responsibly
how can we do so ethically and how can
we do
how can we do so beneficially beneficial
destructively
instead of destructively yeah and in
ways that are consistent with our
our highest values you know our better
angels as opposed to
um are you know the devils and so
that it does feel to me like we're on
this tipping point and
and living in in these in this era
you see kind of um some you know you see
glimpses of this of a future but you're
also kind of
mired in this this past of exploitation
and destruction
um and so there's a kind of uh eeriness
of
and a sense of of um you know a huge
shift that's happening
um that we're part of um but don't fully
understand
and and that to me is really the the
subject of of the book
and it's really um insightful the way
that in each of these different chapters
you look at this shifting baseline
challenge whether it's the trash on the
beach
that seems to have been historic for
some people to the oyster fishermen
there in louisiana who feel like this
has been a way of life forever
and yet you know it wasn't right so the
example you're talking about is one of
the most
fascinating uh climate
adaptation uh projects i guess you could
call it or
or um mitigation litigation project yeah
um
which is that though it's never talked
about that way because it's in the state
of louisiana where
um nobody no elected official can use
the word climate change out of fear of
alienating much of the the voter base um
to read these documents is like a
fascinating um
display of double speak where um
the state bemoans the loss of the the
wetlands on the coast which is our
buffer against hurricanes and sea level
rise yeah i live in new
orleans one of the cities most
threatened by climate change
um in the world at least and certainly
in the western world and
um our our fate depends on um
having this robust barrier of of
marshland
south of new orleans in the southern
coast of louisiana
that marshland has been vanishing for
about a hundred years
for a few reasons the largest ones are
the control of the mississippi river uh
preventing the river from flooding
over time so when it floods it
replenishes
the soil builds it up um and also the
work of the oil and gas industry
carving up the marsh to get to oil wells
and so the state has this incredible
50-year plan extremely i mean talk about
long-term planning it's a 50-year plan
but it's
perpetually renewing so it always looks
at the next 50 years
and the idea is quite literally to
rebuild
the coast and the the best way to do
that
is by altering the flow of the
mississippi river
um basically opening up some control
controlled floods uh through the delta
to recreate land
um and it has unanimous support in
louisiana
uh except for among the people whose
whose uh lives and and homes are most
threatened
by sea level rise which are the people
of the southernmost part of the river
um who are terrified by this this plan
because they think that it will
alter fishing conditions and most of
these people who live down there
are fishermen and to a certain extent
they're right it will change
you know what kind of species they'll be
able to fish and
and to some extent where they'll be able
to live um
and yet it's the kind of uh plan that is
essential if the whole state is going to
survive including the part
of the land where they live and so for
me it's
it's a per this this drama that's going
on now this fight between these poor
fishermen
and the state of louisiana and basically
everyone else in louisiana
is a perfect example of the kind of
thorny
moral questions that are raised by even
the most
prudent um
efforts to intervene in in some kind of
natural devastation
um and so it did i in in thinking about
our conversation today i mean
it raised a question that i i wanted to
pose
to both of you which is that when you
you know are there any examples in the
work that you do in trying to bring back
species um endangered species or extinct
species
where you know you have a clear argument
for why
doing so would be beneficial and yet
even in the best case scenario
it opens up some negative
impacts for some small subset of say the
people or some small
part of an ecosystem i'll let ryan take
that one away because
i'll just answer quickly that of course
um
in in the long now vein what's amazing
about our projects and you
actually getting the chance to
re-interview us and and i want to talk
about that
in in your about the book later um
is of course we have not gotten to a
point where we have passenger pigeons or
mammoths ready to go on the landscape so
a lot of people um even fish and
wildlife service a few years ago said
this is so theoretical right now
we're not going to really you know
elevate it to concern
but every time a species is restored
somewhere or there's a plan talked about
these things
there's a subset of people whose lives
are going to change
and it's always a concern to them is it
going to be a negative
change benign or neutral but
in one of our newer projects since we
first spoke back then
there's definitely an economic sector
that does not want change and ryan is
very intimately familiar with that
one of the projects that has been uh
near and dear to us for the last three
years at revive and restore
is the um trying to help save the
horseshoe crab
literally um you know one of the oldest
uh species on the planet that has
prevailed
is almost identical to what it was as a
fossil millions of years ago
and uh every year it spawns along the
eastern coastline and it's
eggs and are used as an incredible
resource to
migratory birds that you know it's a
very very important ecosystem
occurrence and i learned
um three or four years ago that the
horseshoe crabs were actually bled
um by companies to use this very unique
property this protein in their blood
that is a natural
endotoxin detector so it helps secure
and has secured the safety of vaccines
for literally um 30 years now
before that they used rabbits for
testing but the truth is
there's been a synthetic alternative a
recombinant dna
product that's identical to that protein
that is so unique to the horseshoe crab
blood but there's a vested interest
uh into continuing to bleed these crabs
that cost
basically nothing because they're just a
wild animal extract
and to bring it to the pharmaceutical
industry to
make sure all our drugs and vaccines are
safe
that vested interest in doing business
the old way
has just kept this progress from
happening in the level that it should
and luckily the good news to the story
is that eli lilly has been at the
forefront as a pharmaceutical company
even now has a covid19 antibody
treatment that has been
moved all the way through production
using the recombinant dna product so
you know we're thrilled at that but we
need all pharmaceutical companies to be
doing this
not just one yeah i mean i can't i can't
help but think
of i mean there's a there's a very close
analog
and and one of the stories i wrote about
in second nature which is the
first the first piece is about dupont
and this incredible
story of a lawyer who is a
defense lawyer for chemical companies in
cincinnati from a very conservative firm
who because of a family um
association with his grandmother um he
took on this
this case for a cattle farmer in west
virginia who thought that
the local dupont uh company was
poisoning his cattle
and nobody believed him he was in this
big dupont town in west virginia and
this lawyer
named rob balat using um because he knew
these companies inside and out because
he defended chemical companies
um over the course of you know years and
ultimately decades he was able to
unravel this
incredible i think it's safe to say it's
one of if not the the most one of the
greatest
if not the greatest um corporate
conspiracies in
in american history which is that in the
in the manufacture of teflon and other
you know products that that dupont made
billions of dollars off of a year in
profit
they were using this man-made chemical
called pfoa that
doesn't biodegrade and that is a toxin
and is now years later um
part of our biological inheritance it's
in it's in all of our
our bloodstream um because we've been
exposed to such high levels over
over decades um but the connection to
the to
to the crabs is that what he found at
one point in his
in his research and he read millions of
pages of documents of
internal memos from dupont is that
uh by the i think it was by the early
90s
they'd been making this stuff for since
the 50s by the early 90s
uh dupont understood that this was
poisonous this was this was toxic and
that um people were
dying and having all kinds of horrible
health conditions who are exposed to it
and they had a replacement they had what
was seen as a benign
excuse me a relatively benign
replacement chemical
that did the same thing but
broke down much more quickly and so and
they just kept doing business as usual i
mean it sounds like
yes and the executive said that the
health people were like oh we should
definitely
do this and and the business executive
said well
we're already on the hook for decades of
this
if we get caught as they ultimately were
by the lawyer
we're already culpable so we're not
going to increase our culpability
and furthermore if we change to this new
unproven
chemical who knows maybe the products
won't be as good
and that was enough just just the sort
of fear of some slight
alteration in their um in their business
plan
that might cost them some part of their
you know billion dollars a year profit
that was enough for them
not to do the right thing and it kept
happening over and over
as you know they got in more and more
hot water more the public began to get
more aware of the issue there were lots
of off-ramps and they never
took one until they were forced right
and that's it does force you you know
it's easy to say
oh that's the evilest company in the
world which you know you could say
um but it does seem to get at something
that
that is um unerraticable from our
species it's a certain kind of way of
thinking that if you
if you allow people not to um do the
right thing
too many of them often will not yeah
well you definitely
have a theme going through your book of
uh of some of the
downside of corporate uh behavior
that uh is really sobering i have to say
robert
uh balot um it becomes a real hero in
that chapter and
i like the way you close saying that he
now is representing
uh you know 230 million americans
in his next lawsuit on behalf of of all
americans
um ensuring that they do the right thing
yeah i mean he started as representing
this cattle farmer and he's
what then he was representing everybody
in these communities in west virginia
now he's
he has a lawsuit on behalf of every
american and the only thing that's not
stopping him from suing on behalf of
every
person and human and and not only human
but you know biological organism in the
world because the stuff has been found
in the blood of you know albatrosses in
the middle of the ocean
um is that is uh you know jurisdiction
but he's
he's taking them as far as as he can go
and and
and balad is um who
you know has become a kind of national
hero he was and he was the
the story became a movie uh called dark
waters that i'd encourage everyone to
see where mark ruffalo plays
uh the lot um but but he he's beco
for me he he was a kind of avatar for
all of us in a certain sense and that he
had the kind of
awakening moment where everything that
he thought to be true in his case
he thought that for instance
corporations
um wanted to do the right thing they
wanted to
to behave responsibly that um you know
they wanted to follow regulations and so
on
um was was false and and
and furthermore that you know the idea
that we were all
um that we weren't affected by some of
this malfeasance was also turned out to
be
false and and he responds with this
um a level of anger i think
and frustration and bitterness that i
think is is an important part of
of how uh a lot of us feel when we are
forced to reckon with some of these
these realities you know the idea that
what we think of as
you know wild forest in north america
for instance
um is such a degraded version of what
they
have been and what they could be um
that it you know i think angered you
know a lot of the early stories in the
book i think
when people are having this moment of
reckoning that's a common response i
think that's
um you know i identify with that a
feeling of betrayal
um that what we've thought is not true
anymore yeah
yeah so the transformation that blot
goes through as a corporate defense
attorney
now working on behalf of all americans
in a sense and all living organisms
um is an interesting shift and
there's another hopeful one going on
with people that are
traditional conservationists and you
have a chapter
in your book um uh where you refer to
the um the wasting and it's about the
sunflower sea star here all along our
western coast of
uh california all the way up to alaska
then in 2013 had an incredible
uh die back from this wasting disease it
is still
considered to have an unknown origin
some assume it's climate change
acidification
an unknown pathogen and i thought
it would be interesting to give you a
little bit of an update from revive and
restore because we're not just the
extinction folks we also are very much
about genetic rescue
and two years ago we started a catalyst
science fund
to fund researchers working at this
bleeding edge
of research bringing biotech to
conservation
and we've been funding at the university
of california at merced
two scientists um mike dawson and um
lauren shuttlebutt um who are working
on the underlying genomics that are
uh potentially making sea stars
um more susceptible to this wasting
syndrome
and i think this is the awakening that
many conservationists
have come to which is that the oceans
that they've been protecting
um are not the same as they were a
decade ago
coral kelp sea stars are
going through major shifts and they're
witnessing it
in their own eyes as they go and dive
and see a completely
different now urchin baron and realizing
that
maybe they have to deploy new tools for
conservation
you know i think i think in this entire
conversation
uh uh we've kind of hit at
what what you said nathaniel this this
very human condition you know we
it's easy to target a corporation and
say
oh they looked the other way for a
profit but it really is
innate in every human discipline that
that we we so often times have solutions
to our problems for decades
without using them because business as
usual feels good
it's rewarding right now and there's no
crisis
point even if it's slowly building up
we'll be like oh it's it's slow it's
slow and then all of a sudden you have a
heat wave come through in 2013
wipes out more than 90 percent of the
sea stars and now we have to do
something
incred you know very very extreme about
it um
which needs new tools right so i mean
conventional measures before might have
been doing
if you had intervened before
conventional measures might have done
something and that's a
um that's a neat kind of thread between
all of these with the horseshoe crab
story where
we've had us we've had a synthetic
alternative for over 20 years that has
barely been adopted
um in the in the dupont story where they
had a replacement but didn't adopt it
all the way to
the you know issues of the coastline in
louisiana
amsterdam and the netherlands has been
controlling the entire ocean for decades
and we've never adopted any of that in
the united states um that
that's so many of these tools we needed
right now but we wait to the point of
crisis
and then we need something new and uh
you know
i'm i'm interested a little bit to hear
nathaniel's
uh opinion on on you know
that phenomena because of course revive
and restore where we're
and we're pushing for those new tools
um not just in response to crisis
but to use them as a management tool
periodically so that we don't end up in
more crises
and and that is where we fit so nicely
and long now because it's it's you have
to be thinking
in terms of long management not just
response to right now um
yeah i already no i think that's really
well put
um then i mean it it was also that was
also the subject of my my last book
called losing earth which is about this
period
in the 1980s where you know the
consensus on climate change was
crystallized there was clear responses
um policy responses that were understood
and promoted
and nothing ultimately ended up
happening and it was before you have the
oil and gas industry emerging as this
this comic book villain trying to squash
any effect
any any effort um at climate policy
um you know before before we had this
this um
this arch enemy uh we failed on our on
our own essentially and it's about well
how did that happen
why before the issue was politicized why
did we find it so hard to move
forward um and i think i mean the
the conservation element of this that
that's so central to
the work at revive and restore
um for me is really at the heart of a
lot of
of how i think about these issues and
and and not just
the work that you do but these ideas of
of intervention and you know what point
do we start intervening
or intervening more um purposefully i
should say
um and and how far should we take it and
so on and i i was really struck
um when i first met with uh
with you all i think there was a a lunch
i had with with ryan
and and stuart um where i have it at my
desk because i actually do keep it this
isn't just a prop i keep it um
nearby you gave me a copy of this book
nature's
oh great by mark it's good um
it's really good and and it's it's a
history of of conservation essentially
um conservation movement and or the
thinking that that
inspired it and i was really struck by
this idea of a marriage between the most
futuristic technologies that uh
things like you know crispr and genetic
engineering to
recreate or create new novel versions of
of lost species
um or to rescue endangered species um
and and this this uh
history of thought that really dates to
the the is really the foundation of the
environmental
movement as we know it um that goes back
to
you know 19th century um thinkers like
uh you know
humboldt and and and uh george perkins
marsh and so on
and and that was very surprising to me
because it's not what i'd really seen in
reading about
you know um the work that george church
was doing for instance
that that you're involved with it at
harvard or you know some of the
when you read about these futuristic
technologies they don't tend to talk
about
19th century thought but actually it
made total sense to me that
that one should first identify you know
what we're trying to conserve
what we're trying to to restore um
or bring back uh before we start getting
into
the technology and and i was curious i
mean
it's something that i wanted to ask you
further about and
as you've you're now so much further
into your work and you're doing all this
this great work with genetic rescue um
you know how much how central is that
kind of thinking
in in your day-to-day work as you as you
make choices about you know what species
to take on or you know where to
um focus your energies um how much do
you think of these principles of
of of conservation um you know is that
is that core to your decision making
process as you as you move forward
yeah and well conservation is absolutely
core to what we're doing
that's why restore is part of our name
it's very much about
ecological restoration um
the black-footed ferret is a really good
example of a species that
should have still be prevailing from
mexico to the
canadian border excuse me
um the black-footed ferret was as a
project was brought to us by u.s fish
and wildlife service saying
you know can you help us with
potentially a bottleneck
issue with the species it is all so
closely related
having started with just seven founders
when they were thought to be extinct
um we've recently just announced uh the
cloning
of the first black-footed ferret which
is the first
cloning of a native american endangered
species
and um we knew that you know going down
this path three years ago would be
controversial
but we're very pleased to say that
the public and conservationists have
taken it as a very serious
um conservation event that
this is a milestone that endangered
species could be cloned
could increase genetic variation and
really contribute to the
sustainability of a species long-term
yeah i think it's it's what's really
cool
about the reception we've had for
cloning black-footed ferrets
is everything we're talking about right
now you know what you dawned on this
idea of marrying
uh this this long-term historic context
of conservation with the future
technologies is that
elizabeth and the ferret literally
embodies that as the fact that
to bring new genetic diversity into her
population today for the future we had
to reach
into the past to do it um and the only
way to reach into that past was through
biotechnology
you know there's a lot going on and
especially in the sciences um but also
really in sort of
ethics or you know on the vanguards of
vanguard of how we think about um these
major issues like
uh that that you're involved the kind of
work that you're involved in
um and it's often not until
somebody writes about it um or creates
art about it
uh that the public is able to
really grapple with it in a serious way
um you know the final
the final story in in second nature is
called green rabbit and it's about this
this art scandal um years ago where
a brazilian chicago artist named eduardo
katz created this um artwork that was a
a glow-in-the-dark um like neon green
bunny rabbit and it turned
and people freaked out and they said you
know how dare you design
a species for you know for art for
artistic
um response and and uh
this is unethical and so on and what he
pointed out is that he hadn't actually
done
anything he just you know these rabbits
were being created by french institutes
to do research on vaccines and
and other things and other kinds of
human medicine and it was only that
that cats brought it forward into the
public glare
um that people freaked out but as you
know
he hadn't he hadn't created something
new he had reflected what was going on
already and i think that i think there's
real value in that kind of work because
i think most of us don't really
who aren't in your sort of world of of
you know on the on the
on the front lines of this technological
advancement
don't really think ethically or morally
uh
or even conceptually about some of these
vast changes that are
ongoing and i think there's there's a
role there for writing in particular
particularly imaginative writing not
just pure reporting but
but you know immersive uh narrative
um that allows us to really work through
some of these these major
transformations that are ongoing and and
i think it's
it's a necessary part frankly of uh
you know the cultural response to these
these these issues and
that you know we won't adapt these new
technologies many of which are hugely
important for our
you know survival um until we're really
able to think
think through them in a more profound
way exactly
you know um i i love that chapter for a
number of reasons one
cat's the artist you're referring to
says the function of art is to expose
areas of life that we don't have the
proper language to describe
and that uh very often when a new
problem
emerges and it experts in the field
develop their own consensus on it but
takes much longer for that technology
to be actually adopted uh by the public
but by the time
it's already out there in the culture
the technology has moved ahead there's
this
there's this lag that happens and i
think that
um you know it certainly was the case
with in vitro fertilization
that uh once it was out there um
it moved very fast through the through
the society and i suspect the same thing
will be happening
with precision editing um yeah we're in
i believe 2020 2020 one of the first
years of human clinical trials for
gene editing therapies just less than
eight years
less than less than 10 years after gene
editing from crispr cast 9 was actually
harnessed
but not for heritable um correct
changes so that'll come and that will
come well
it's species for other species first and
that was an idea also that was in
that that i i first thought about um
thanks to one of our original
conversations because i remember
um ryan that you speaking about
um what you were doing not just as a you
know science project or
and not just as a conservation project
but as um
a kind of storytelling project and i i
found that very
fascinating that that it wasn't enough
to
to you know make your arguments about
why a certain innovation should happen
or to perfect the science you also had
to bring the culture along
with you and i think that that is
something that's really lost by
by most people who who are who are doing
the kind of
work well not that not a lot of people
are doing exactly the kind of work that
you're doing but
but on you know on the front lines of
these these technological shifts
really don't stop to think about that or
to think about it in any
depth and i think there's there's real
value in that exercise and i would say
in fact it's it's necessary that we have
to have these kinds of thought
experiments and for most people
who might not understand you know crispr
or you know cast nine uh to think about
to think in those terms is actually
valuable
and it's it's a you know it's an example
again that i think comes from
conservation
um where you have every you know every
conservation group has as its mascot
some cuddly animal um and there's a
reason for that and i think it it
actually serves a purpose
um that that one should take seriously
you know
what's really interesting there is is
you know you talked about your book
being timeless
and and as i read the last page that all
finally makes sense to me now because i
read the last sentence and i was kind of
like
it didn't end right i i felt like
i was i was like and then ryan i talked
a little bit
about it and she was like oh and she
kind of made me understand it a bit more
and my head was a little bit too much in
the science
um and not enough in the art and
and you know the guy talks about you
know art lagging behind
you know reality whereas we've done
something kind of fundamentally
different with de-extinction
we see it as an extension of things
conservation has already been doing
but we're bringing in new tools and
because we announced we wanted to do
this
before it was done there's actually been
like a wave of art
and discussion and dialogue where the
mascot
is de-extinction and it hasn't been
reality yet i think we've done something
really
incredibly different and in that line of
and that's where the storytelling is so
important and and why i'm really happy
that your book is coming out with that
one chapter about it embedded in this
bigger context
because the storytelling now becomes
really really imperative
and a lot of people have been missing
the conservation connection and i'm
going to weave something crazy for you
right now because here's how the
storytelling has
has come back to something in your
backyard is for years
people would ask things about well what
are the unintended consequences
of bringing back a passenger pigeon or a
woolly mammoth you know jurassic park
being the the cultural motif that people
fall back to
and even us with our heads in
conservation couldn't say
a lot about well how many times has it
gone right how old is this
and just in the last couple years we've
started putting our heads together on
the work we've been amassing and we
published a paper on
translocations it's part of a bigger
issue special issue on a lot of things
in conservation
but it turns out you know that the idea
of restoring a species in an area
or saving it in one area for later the
idea of moving animals around
intentionally this management this thing
that you hit on so much in your book
about
actually intervening with thought goes
way back
um and one of the first ones is in 1895
by
edward avery mckinley
mikhail henney with the snowy egrets on
avery island he moved
snowy egrets which were the rallying
charismatic animal for the audubon
society
and he moved them onto avery island and
they took off did really well and it was
actually that population that made it
possible
to restore and save snowy egrets in
florida
and now today 120 years later
avery island is threatened by climate
change
in louisiana and so it's like it's the
home of an intervention that was very
proactive
helped save things was very futuristic
at the time
and now because of this weird slump back
into everyday's usual thinking it needs
more intervention to be saved and i
think you know it's
it's what's been beautiful in reading
your book for me is learning
just how much you really can interweave
so many very disparate things
into this common narrative well the
avery and also
i mean for for viewers who don't have
the association
that is that i i i have since
childhood avionics where they make
tabasco hot sauce and and mclehaney is
the family that that makes it
and i should say some of the some of his
um
projects didn't work out as well i mean
i think he helped bring the
the nutria um which is this just just
disgusting um rodent god bless it
um with yellow teeth that just that is
also one of the factors uh a significant
factor in
um the destruction of the marsh because
it chews on roots of marsh plants
and and there are so many they've so
over bred
that um they have significantly weakened
the the uh the marsh uh
in south louisiana um but it is
it does raise another fascinating issue
which is that
you know it it's not just it's not about
restoring something that's lost you have
to pick
you know where in the timeline you know
you want to
to restore there's a there's almost a
sort of perversely curatorial
quality of it i mean i think with the
the sea stars
and correct me if this if the scientific
understanding of this has
advanced um ryan and ben but
one of the one of my sources was saying
well it may be
that this ubiquity of these beautiful
sea stars along the pacific coast that
is now under threat because of
wasting syndrome that the ubiquity
itself
is a is a human phenomenon that
basically because of human activities
and fishing activities along the pacific
coast
in the 20th century and 19th century um
we've created conditions for this these
species to overpopulate
and maybe now what's you know what seems
like a total uh devastating
um you know epidemic is actually arrest
restoring back to more natural levels
of the species i don't know if that's i
don't buy it
i don't buy it at all because now what
we have are
are just total urchin barons it's really
a crisis
you know is what was is the you know
were the populations
in you know 2010 was that the ideal
population was it the populations in
1970 was the population
20 you know fair point and those are
difficult conversations that
um and i'm really i'm not going to go
out of my realm here but ben i know
there's some
some question also about um passenger
pigeons and where
where was that population um you know
was that
naturally in the flocks of billions and
billions or does that itself have
you know based on interactions with
other species and human activities and
so on
the population history of passenger
pigeons was actually the missing hole
in explaining their natural history that
was actually the first significant
surprise in our data
we were not surprised that europeans had
not tampered with it but
a lot of people had come up with a bunch
of different ideas the most provocative
popularized by charles mann was that
you know after europeans arrived in 1491
and brought disease
very poignant for right now and wiped
out the first nations people that
their population collapse allowed
passenger pigeons to soar
right and that was an absolutely absurd
idea that had no science behind it at
the time even
but it became very popular and um
and we actually invented several
hypotheses as to when passenger pigeon
populations became large
and it was in the genetic data that they
were all blown out of the water and so
it turned out that passenger pigeons had
likely numbered in the billions for uh
before human beings ever even set foot
on north american soil
um and and so they've been a very stable
constant part of the environment even
while the environment changed climates
and changed regimes
um so that that's that's worth that
situation happy to talk
more there but is that how you get to
the this idea
of them being the the um architect of
the
yeah yes that was that was actually it
was the one piece of data missing from
completing that hypothesis that other
people had said right they're like well
maybe their impact was beneficial and it
was
very important when we looked at the
forest that was the other thing i saw
that when you look at even the trees the
trees themselves the other animals
they're all
highly evolved for living in a system
that's in constant flux
and their traits for doing that are
traits that would have had to have
accumulated
tens of thousands if not millions of
years over millions of years
um and so it's it's definitely not a
recent phenomenon and that's another
reason
that's that's a that story by itself
is not is not isolated to passenger
pigeons that's what more people are
learning of course the way that we think
about it is in terms of biodiversity and
a healthy biodiversity
and so it's not as if there's
necessarily a particular baseline that
has to be
met but when when you know that you're
losing
sea stars you're losing kelp and you if
you lose the kelp
you lose the fish and if you lose a fish
you know it's just working their way
right up
you know it creates a cascade of
problems
same thing in louisiana now you've got
forests coming back they're very
different for us
but you've got birds coming back in some
areas
and you know it's it's going to create a
greater
biodiversity different than it once was
but it's very different
than the actual wasteland that parts of
louisiana are experiencing so
you know i think we're all learning
right
yeah and you know what's really
interesting there
comes back to this idea um of of you
know continually updating knowledge
is that um
something that's not talked about a
great deal in this science is the
science of ecology is that even concept
of baseline
is is a difficult one because every
baseline before the year 1935 is
theoretical
um you know ecology wasn't a science
until the 30s and the problem with it
becoming a science in the 30s
is it became a science in the united
states
and in the 1930s we hit our lowest
forest points
in history we had already irrigated and
destroyed wetlands i mean most of the
ecosystems people were looking at in the
1930s
were at their most impoverished point in
the last thousand years
um and so what's weird to me about
dialogues about overpopulation
and what we've heard from other
scientists in this space is that
we actually have been trained for
decades to think of populations at the
levels they were at their lowest point
and when they start coming back we start
fretting and thinking oh
this is overpopulation um when it's
actually not um
and so we have to go back to you know a
previous state and look at fossil
records and and now edna
things coming out that could help with
this and learn that
um it's really difficult to entangle and
of course before europeans you have
first nations people managing the
environment but
in general i would say the last 500
years of european colonization of the
world has
has devastated ecosystems and anything
that has come back or started to rise up
in that point in time
um is that bioabundance is a good thing
over usually we should probably wrap it
up
and um i wanted to ask you one more
question about the title of this book
second nature um say a little bit more
what you actually meant by that
that's a good question um second nature
i think has to i mean there there's a
there's a pun there
um you know you have this idea
it picks up on the idea that um
one takes what's familiar as for granted
you know that that conditions i mean ben
you were talking about ecology
uh in the 1930s taking for granted that
this
this fallen state of the the planet was
the natural
you know baseline um i think we all do
that
in our own way and so there's this idea
that
you know the expression second nature i
think evokes one's you know taking for
granted that this is just
this is this is the natural world as we
know it um and any
deviation from it um seems
odd um but but what what so many of
these
the the people i write about and in the
in these stories
encounters that they realize that
actually
you know in order to get back to
something that that does
that is more natural that that is more
biodiverse that is
um more ethical we actually have to
deviate quite a lot
from what we've been doing um and so
you get to the idea of a second nature
of a new a new
relationship with nature that
acknowledges that
that difficult reality and acknowledges
that
um what you know we have to think in a
longer time
frame we have to think beyond just the
immediate moment we have to think
both about you know the recent and
distant past and and the
the near and distant future um
and with that i think becomes a new
understanding
of the natural world and understanding
of a new kind of ecology really i think
we're at
at the beginning of a new phase of of
ecological
thinking uh in this country that that
you know organizations like like
revive and restore are are sort of
pushing pushing us to consider um
that intervention is not always about it
and in fact in many cases it's it's
necessary and it's it's
you know that that some sometimes these
these what seem to be really radical
departures
uh from the status quo are actually um
necessary to preserve um what we want to
what we worry about having lost well
long now always says
we want to make long-term thinking
automatic and common
not difficult and rare and i think one
of the things that
second nature has done a really great
job at pointing out
is how important our thinking about the
long term is
and how equally important is the
short term actionability so thank you
for
bringing all this to the forefront in in
such an engaging way
well thank thank you for your help and
inspiring this
it i really owe a lot to um
those early conversations that i had
with you and and
and from learning about the work that
you're you're doing was very
um central to the conception of this
this book so i'm i'm grateful
to you and grateful for this chance to
talk with you both
great thank you ben thank you nathaniel
thank you long now
thank you
[Music]